x-ray take one Apple take two Baker on
the bark oh I'm going to be at the gym
for the first time in my life that
doesn't hurt it's not real oh so good
what in God's name are you to Jezebel's
to be here let's go again try as you
might
most of it was blood money that you
inherited from the blossoms that I never
should have let you keep in the person
first place first place distributors
distributors distributors that mad dog
was right I saw government gargoyles
gargoyles it's really hard to say the X
in I'm not gonna live it all together
fizzle rocks distributors fizzle rocks
douche feeders haha okay ready let's go
you faked a great stone and free wink at
me we get me for Town white start at the
beginning
there was a big bang
that's Archie he's graceful he's a
dancer plays little music as they say in
France being evolute Ella Elio is giving
me the chance of a lifetime you're 21
what do you know but a lifetime that's
the idea nobody look just look into my
eyes again I thought we were keeping
that offset unless you have a better
idea
[Music]
this just goes to show you would be
nothing without your big lips anything
[Music]
like no it's all the way in the back all
the way to the hottest summer in
Riverdale Oh hot dogs
[Music]